all right experts have been saying for
months that president biden's border
crisis had major national security
implications just kind of no one kind of
left it off right many people just said
overstating it to get attention well
guess what
last week a 21 year old potential
terrorists with terrorist ties was
captured along the border after legally
entering in yuma arizona the man
allegedly from saudi arabia is linked to
several yemeni subjects of interest on
the terror networks he was wearing a
jacket with an american flag patch and
another that said central oneeta county
volunteer that's up in albany new york
now the good news is he was caught but
given the biden administration's effort
to declaw a border patrol is it just a
matter of time before someone like him
breaks through or did they already
joining us right now tom homan former
acting ice director extremely frustrated
and fox news contributor tom when this
news crossed you're one of the few that
was not surprised right
right i've been saying all year long
when you open the border up to illegal
immigration which takes half the bore
patrol off the line
you open it up to criminals you open up
to human trafficking on women and
children and you open it up to terrorism
look borbacho bryan borbatro has already
arrested over 15 people
on the on the terrorist screening
database 15. this is just the latest so
we know they've released 600 000 into
the country this past year and we know
there's 400 000 got aways people didn't
get apprehended and escaped we know that
from camera traffic
drone traffic sensor traffic
so terrorists don't want to get arrested
so how many of that 400 000
didn't get arrested and they're
terrorists
i want to bring you to something else
that came up over the weekend on face
the nation uh the newest drug czar said
we know exactly what's going on with
fentanyl it's killing
teens and young adults at a dizzying
number at a record pace we know that
china makes it gives it to the drug
cartels in mexico it comes across it
infiltrates into every major city and
small town in america you know what they
forgot to ask margaret brennan
what does it mean to have the border
wide open that the cartels are able to
make more money easier and get more
fentanyl across without even fearing any
type of retribution
well exactly like i said when you open
the border of illegal immigration i know
for a fact 40 to 50 percent of the
border patrol is not on the line yuma
last week there wasn't anybody on the
border for days at a time and del rio
with the haitian surge that happened
last month 224 miles of border unguarded
for days so look the border's wide open
and i i'm i'm telling dea is on the
record 95 in the fentanyl that enters
this country comes to the southwest
border we got over 100 000 fentanyl
overdose deaths it's not a coincidence
at the same year you have historic
illegal immigration numbers
at the same time have historic fentanyl
overdose deaths it's not a coincidence
that border is open to drug smugglers
and the cartels don't
democrat or republican it's right and
wrong
it's not even hard are you pro crime or
against crime are you pro opening up our
country's security or against it it's
not even hard stuff and i think the
american people are waking up because
sadly fentanyl is affecting so many
people and so many different walks of
life
thanks so much tom holman hopefully
people start listening to you soon
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else